chris pratt you like getting naked
yeah
yeah i liked i i've i've spent a good
amount of time naked yeah yeah
like even when you were a kid
i was always getting naked i was always
getting in trouble for getting naked
they're like you can't just pull your
dick out i like why
that is funny
baby i'm back
thank you
so sorry all right
because the lady who who owned the place
was like listen if you ever want to eat
something you just eat something just
make sure you write it down we'll give
you the give it to you for half price
and then we'll take it out of your check
i was like cool so it was kind of a
credit system yeah and i worked there
for i think i got paid every two weeks
and i got my first check and they were
like okay let's just see uh here's what
you got you owe us eighty dollars
[ __ ] my pants on camera
we celebrated our valentine's day uh
last weekend oh you did yeah oh that's
good that's always better easier to get
a dinner reservation yeah all everything
is easier yeah yeah completely but there
i did get her a little something oh you
did yeah for tomorrow for tomorrow oh
and now the surprises i guess ruin oh
she doesn't watch you oh she's not
watching okay
we get along really well you're so
prestastic take your hand off sorry
it's a good comeback story right
seabiscuit the mighty ducks robert
downey jr
rocky yes kim kardashian kim well well
in the video she gets she gets come on
her back i think
pratt must be a is it a german name no i
don't i don't believe it is i don't
believe it is i don't believe pratt's
german i know that in england it means
douche
and slo that's what i was getting
american english i'm turning it into
that as well
this is really embarrassing to do in
front of a whole room full of brits here
but i'll try it anyways so like honestly
i like i saw this guy
honestly
like michael cheated on me when he was
in a beef heart and i was like
because he's telling me he's like you
know no i miss you or whatever and i'm
like
you miss me what am i your mother
there was a restaurant in parks and rec
called the jurassic fork right oddly and
that was where uh we would go to eat and
they gave us you know dinosaur sized
portions and so
i didn't have anything to say in the
scene so inevitably i wanted to try to
get some screen time so i decided i
would eat one rack of ribs per take
and if the camera happened to catch me i
would absolutely be just inhaling ribs
the whole rack the whole rack like 12 of
them yep i went through 12 takes i went
through 12 racks of ribs
which is the equivalent
of six pigs
yes
i dined on the ribs of six different
pigs
and every time
ever after every take nick offerman
whose laugh is like this he goes
so if i can make him laugh it's it
tickles me to no end and so i knew it
was making nick laugh i was making
myself sick but i had 12 racks of ribs
and then at lunch
because our catering company was
creating the ribs they cooked ribs
and uh at lunch i sat down with another
four racks of ribs
right next to nick and ate the ribs
uh i got a big laugh i think i gave
myself like
dear christ oh my god that was a bad one
oh no guys sorry
oh it's sausage and brisket and all
kinds of [ __ ]
oh it's so hot it's hot in my nose it's
hot like gasoline
to be scared a lot in the movie you have
to be you must have really worked on
your scared face yo yeah yeah
oh jesus
are we doing a bit
now this
is classic christmas i've never heard a
christmas wish
[Music]
[Music]
what body part are you most proud of
think about it
my skull
it's very thick it's a good one
and uh jacob hey do you want some of
mine
[Laughter]
come to sherm's
this is the one that i i keep in my
bathroom there you are
[Applause]
yeah
there it is
look at those
my name is mika
i am a translator
everything he says is ridiculous so i'm
going to make up my own things to say
they are they are so cocky
and rude they are they're terrible
americans
their movie is only okay
[Music]
if i am left to my own devices
i'm like you know how like if you
accidentally dump a whole jar of
goldfish food in with the fish it'll die
it'll like eat all of it it won't know
when to stop that's me that's you yeah
like if i get trapped in a sizzler
for a weekend
i'd be i let's hope that doesn't happen
all right that would be kind of a good
way to go yeah i had i had three faces i
did on this one can we see him here's
fear
okay you want to see love yeah
and then i had like like just pure joy
sometimes when i wipe
i'll wipe and i'll wipe and i'll wipe
and i'll wipe
a hundred times
still poop still poop let me check that
it's like i'm wiping a marker or
something
what did you think you would have done
but you haven't done yet by this age
been in jail
there's time yeah
dude
let's just bang one out should we
you mean have sex
no
oh i just
maybe i mean what are you talking about
no i mean i don't you know i know
nothing you know it's just it's i'm
married oh yeah me too yeah me too yeah
no because the cameras i get it i have
hot snakes you guys what's hot snakes
it's when the diarrhea comes out like a
hot snake candy
i get hot snakes in bubble gut
hello sir hello sir were you out with a
lady last night sir oh did you want it
sir oh
yeah we met with a lady last night sir
oh
hi chris pratt i have i have a question
for mr chris pratt yes tom go right
ahead so so my question for you is um of
all the actors in the world of all of
the actors who
who is who is your favorite actor
these are people he worked with you're
talking about just anyone oh okay
all of them all the actors in the world
go ahead denzel
denzel washington yeah yeah he's great
no don't applaud don't applaud
i'm sorry okay yeah that's cool i like
denzel too um
okay how do i okay what about how about
an actor whose name begins with tom
oh how about that
tom cruise
he's great he's good top gun he's coming
out he's good he's got okay i could
simplify it for you again
what if his second name began with an h
tom h oh
hanks
beautiful day in the neighborhood yeah
that was good too it was good yeah real
good he's british
all right
he's british
oh i see where this is going okay
we've got him now tom hardy
he played venom yeah he was very he was
great warrior great movie yeah okay can
that answer your question
try younger
but still with the
still with the tom h you're still with
the tom h thanks oh wow
hiddleston oh yeah
is she lewis going to be here yeah yeah
[Applause]